hey guys
today i want to talk to you about
something that is extremely important
a lot of men in this world they start
off great
they want to make a difference
in this world they want to be real men
of value
but then somewhere
in their life something change
they change
they change because their knees bowed
down to the influence of this world
bad friends corrupt governments
relationship issues the loss of loved
ones
health problems
money
addiction
fame selfishness
basically evil
they are overcome
with evil
let me ask you something today
and be honest
how do you view
yourself right now what is your life
like
what is your perception about yourself
this world and your purpose in it
are you being overcome by evil some guys
say well if you can't fight them join
them
now that is weakness talking
if you do that then you will become what
you hate
there's a lot of people who say that
this world is a terrible place
crime
injustice hate
war
poverty
hurt there's a lot of hurt pain and
suffering but think about this why is it
like this
it's because of us
humans with our sinful natures edmund
burke said the only thing necessary for
the triumph of evil is for good men to
do nothing
you have to be watchful you have to
stand firm in the faith act like men
be strong
because think about this how can you
live with yourself if you don't stand up
for what you believe in
you can't
so be a man of value albert einstein
said try not to become a man of success
but rather try to become a man of value
are you a man of value
what do you bring to the people around
you
or
are you one of those people who just
want to receive you just want to take
and take and take and take until there's
nothing left
just to live
selfishly in this
short temporary world until the day you
die
you might be rich you might die with a
big house
but guess what you will not take that
with you when you die
there is no purpose in that
and for what
i mean this life goes by so fast in the
twinkling of an eye for you are both a
mist that appears for a little while and
then
vanishes
living ass being a man of value is far
more worth than any material thing that
this world can offer you
living a life where you are honest
diligent empathetic unselfish humble
confident
disciplined hard-working loyal not
holding grudges generous and where you
have good morals
values
if you live this way and if you do so
consistently you will not just bring
value to your own life but to those
around you as well you will nurture your
own character
and also be an inspiration for those
around you for your family and your
friends
do not
let the evil of this world bring you
down
do not be overcome by evil but overcome
evil with
good
and did you know that you can choose to
be a man of value yes it is a choice
a man whose family looks up to him a man
whose friends want to be like him
because he inspires them to be better to
be good
he leads the way
to making this world a better place for
his family for his friends and even for
people he do not know
because
it is just the right thing to do
to bring light into darkness
guy kawasaki said it is better to fail
at doing the right thing than to succeed
at doing the wrong thing
i want to ask you to just stop for a
second start with this rat race
stop doing whatever you are doing right
now
sit back
look at your life assess the situation
think about what you're doing and if you
continue this way where will you be in
10 years from now
are you a man of value
are you doing certain things
that are actually going against your
beliefs just because you want to achieve
success in this short temporary world
worldly success
do not be confirmed to this world but be
transformed by the renewal of your mind
that by testing you may discern what is
the will of god what is good and
acceptable and perfect
to be a man of value you need to be able
to see the bigger picture of life
and then you need to make the necessary
changes
to change yourself to be a better man a
man of value
use the short life that you have been
giving in this world
to bring value to other people
and ask yourself this question how do
you want to be remembered by those you
will leave behind after you die
if you want to understand more of what
i'm actually talking about if you want
to change your life then watch one of
these videos here and i'll see you there
and before you go always remember
life is short
so don't waste
yours
cheers guys